all right so kilgrave was a dick but the
guy knew had a dress what can I say
Jessica Jones
so Jessica Jones is the next Netflix
original series brought to us by marvel
it's in the vein of daredevil it's still
part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
like daredevil was this one follows a
private investigator named Jessica Jones
played by Kristen Ritter can you tell
she's a bit bitter and kind of has an ax
to grind as you learned what has
happened to her you completely get it
Krysten Ritter did a great job playing
that sarcastic I don't give a [ __ ]
Jessica Jones then when she finds out a
man from her past named kilgrave played
by David Tennant I know kilgrave's are
pretty on the nose villainous name they
addressed that in the show has come back
to town she feels obligated to stop him
not only stop him but catch him to prove
this other girl's innocence that's
really important because killgrave has
the ability to make anyone do anything
just by telling them to do it this show
surprised me in the best way possible
because I knew nothing about Jessica
Jones only thing I know about her is
she's an MPC and Marvel heroes other
than that I don't know much in fact
everything I know about her comes from
this show but getting right into it this
show is not really a superhero show
gotta say that about daredevil but in
the end is still a guy he dresses up in
a costume and goes out tries to save a
city jessica jones is a tragedy it's a
very sad story it's a survivor story
jessica jones has super strength in the
show let's get that out of the way but
it never really upstages the drama of
the show really if you shed away the
Marvel lairs and you race the Marvel
name from the show you still have a very
compelling drama see jessica jones has
history with kilgrave really think about
that this guy kept her around as a pet
and just told her to do [ __ ] she didn't
want to do and she did it because that's
his power
she has since gotten away from him but
no matter how you slice it that's
extremely violating I don't think you
can actually review jessica jones and
not touch on this because this is a very
relevant element in the show jessica
jones is a rape victim or a rape
survivor he was violated by kilgrave he
controlled her she was powerless
sexually and actually the rape factor
isn't just a sexual thing it's an
overall concept of kilgrave taking all
power from that person and they show
dealing with that material in a way that
they did away
it's relevant and gritty and respectful
to people who have been through it not
mind control obviously but the metaphor
of it the powerlessness inflicted on
them by another it deserves props it's
one of the things we've seen mind
control in movies and shows before but
never like this there are consequences
in that jessica jones is suffering those
emotional consequences and after they
established that in this show every time
killgrave inflicts that on somebody
you're like you know what he's doing now
you know what it feels like you know
that they're going to have to deal with
that too it's a layer you just don't
expect when you're going into an
adaptation of a Marvel comic book but
here it is and the actions aside I know
I've just now talked up kilgrave as
being a piece of [ __ ] but I am Telling
You David Tennant's performance as
kilgrave makes him one of the most
memorable villains you've seen in a
while this dude charms up every scene
he's in and when he's on screen you
never want that scene to end ever and
then he leaves and you're like oh bring
him back bring back the next kill grave
scene he's menacing he's scary
he's vile he's charming just if you have
a villain checklist he really checks all
of them and the show so establishes how
he's an [ __ ] and he's ruined Jessica
Jones's life that you hate the fact that
you like it when he's on screen there's
this great say there's no spoilers in
here I want to talk about spoilers and
Jessica Jones but I just can't bring
myself to it because you need to
experience it but I have to talk about
this one saying vaguely speaking this
one person I wish I had his superpower
for this team because this person um
actually is him actually this this and
this and he was like do you really
believe that and she was like no so why
would you say something like that tell
me the truth it makes me feel important
and what would you want to do to someone
who said that to you I'd want to slap
them I was like killgrave I recognize
you're a piece of [ __ ] but I would give
you a high-five right now that's what a
show like this should do just having a
villain and making him a villain from
villains sake happens all the time but
when you can take your villain and make
him a human being that takes work that
takes Talent this show does that yeah
Luke Cage is in this show too they're
having a Luke Cage spin-off show he's
getting his own show on Netflix
I thought Luke Cage was great he was a
great supporting character he's
ultimately a love interest for her in
this one and this introduces you to him
in a way where you're interested
enough you're like yeah I totally want
to see you in your own shell let's see
you do stuff you feel like he would
probably be more of a hero than Jessica
Jones Jessica Jones day and day out many
times been like I'm not a hero I'm just
trying to do this one thing the only
real gripes I have about the show
Jessica Jones is there's this one guy
who enters the show and he was perfectly
fine as a love interest for her friend
then they start making him more than he
was and they just start concentrating on
him a little more than they should and I
was like not why he trying to make him
more than he should be I don't know this
guy is a character in Marvel I didn't
know who Jessica Jones was I'm not gonna
know who this [ __ ] is so they take an
entire episode showing him and wrapping
him up and the whole time you're like
let's get back to kilgrave and otherwise
known as the show let's get back to this
story I've been invested in I just felt
like he was a waste of time makes me
think that this show just went on for
about one episode too long and the show
ends in a bit of an anticlimactic kind
of way I'm not I wasn't expecting a huge
Throwdown at the end or anything like
that but I just feel like if they drew
it out for a little bit it could add it
a bit more to the situation bit more to
Jessica Jones character it would have
been a little more fulfilling as it
stands just kind of ends and then it's
over you're like well I'll see you all
in season two but guys in the end
Jessica Jones is another level of grit I
loved it because it shows us that among
all the big Marvel Cinematic Universe
movie we just saw a trailer for civil
war but in order for Marvel to make good
storyteller you don't need all that a
private investigator trying to take down
the guy who wronged her it's what it is
is what Jessica Jones is I love that
Marvel is starting to see that the
personal stories are really what people
want the explosions and the special
effects that comes secondary because the
best moments in here are these moments
of dialogue between Jessica Jones and
kilgrave the verbal battle the Battle of
wit can be every bit as intense as a CGI
fest climax that the biggest budget
movies can buy and if Netflix is the
only way to get it well hey good job
Netflix I look forward to seeing what
you give us on the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I don't rate show so I'm not
going to write this I'm just gonna say
go watch the Jessica Jones it's
fantastic alright guys so jessica jones
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more